and what about travel because I have
histamine intolerance and I can't eat
aged meat travel's a bit tricky because
going out to restaurants and eating
steak isn't an option because steak has
always aged at restaurants so I can
either go out and eat lamb that's
insanely expensive now generally
speaking I literally take an air fryer
ninja XXL sponsor me put it in a
suitcase put it under the plane and air
Fry at the Airbnb that's usually what I
do it's not super glamorous I've also
been known to just pack a bunch of
frozen meat in a suitcase and bring it
with me with my air fryer you can also
do long-term hotels so if you're to stay
somewhere for a week then there are
hotels that have kitchens in them also
you don't really need a kitchen with an
air fryer you could kind of stay in a
hotel and use an air fryer you have to
be a little sneaky because it can get
kind of smoky so it's better to get a
hotel where you can cook outside of the
room with a little patio Hotel patio air
fryer suitcase full of meat girls got to
do what a girl's got to do to not have
arthritis